باعتباري ابن إسرائيلي، كشخص يحمل
جواز سفر إسرائيلي، كشخص لديه
أصدقاء وعائلة هناك،
من الواضح أنه لا أحد يوافق على
ذبح الأبرياء،
وبالطبع أنا قلق على أصدقائي
وعائلتي الموجودين في
إسرائيل.  قلت إنني لا أقف
مع إسرائيل على الإطلاق بشأن ما يجري، وبدأت
أدرك أخيرًا، بسبب
عدم وجود مصطلح أفضل، مدى تعرضي لغسيل دماغ،
هناك وجهة نظر محددة للغاية
للتاريخ، لقد تعلمنا بشكل أساسي
أن مثل الأرض كانت  لقد
تعلمنا أننا حاولنا أن نقدم
لهم حلاً وحاولنا أن نقدم لهم
السلام واستمروا في الهجوم. أنا
لا أقف مع إسرائيل، أنا أقف مع
الشعب الفلسطيني. لا أفهم
كيف يمكننا كيهود أن نقف مكتوفي الأيدي بينما
الأمة تصرخ من أجل الحرية، إنهم
محاصرون هناك، قد لا يكون الأمر
واضحًا مثل وضعهم في
غرف الغاز، لكنها لا تزال
إبادة جماعية